[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Thank you, everyone,
for coming to our talk.
And today, we're
going to tell you
about how you can make your
services more reliable using
Stackdriver.
So today, we have
essentially four things
that we want to tell you about.
First of all, we're going to
talk to you about why DevOps,
why SRE, , kind of how do
these things help you solve
reliability problems.
Then we'll tell you about
three specific things
that GCP and
Stackdriver do in order
to make it possible for you
to achieve SRE principles
on Stackdriver and on GCP.
So we're going to tell you
about how to measure success
with service level objectives.
We're going to tell you about
how to improve your service
level resiliency by having
better alerting and better
debugging.
And then we'll tell you about
how transparent SLIs help
you get shared visibility
into Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm Liz Fong-Jones.
I'm a staff site
reliability engineer.
And I've been working
at Google as a SRE
for about 10 and 1/2 years.
And it's been across
eight different teams,
so I've kind of
spanned everywhere
from consumer-facing products,
like Google Flight Search,
all the way down to low level
storage like Google Cloud
and Bigtable.
And now I work on the Customer
Reliability Engineering
team, which I'll
tell you about later.
But the key mission
that we have is we
help GCP customers build and
operate reliable systems.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES: And
I'm Marie Cosgrove-Davies.
I'm a product manager
on Stackdriver,
focusing on logging.
I'm new to Google, but I've
been in ops for a long time,
and I've had a
number of job titles,
including SRE, product
manager now, and support,
and engineering.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
So first of all, I
wanted to lead off by telling
you about how does SRE
help you improve reliability.
But before I even do that,
I kind of want to lead off
by talking about why
should you care about
reliability, why should
you care about operations.
And this may seem obvious
to some of you who
have done operations before.
To others of you, it
may be a new concept
that as people who
develop software,
we tend to spend a
lot of time thinking
about when does my feature ship.
OK, you know, I spent a
month shipping my feature.
I spent six months
shipping my feature.
What happens afterwards?
And it turns out that if
you spend a month developing
your feature, it might take a
month's worth of support work
later, or it might even
take 10 times as much.
You might wind up
spending-- for every month
that you spend
developing a feature,
it may end up having someone
spend a year supporting it.
So it's really, really critical
that we think about how do we
improve the interoperability
of our services
to lower the cost of
ownership of our services.
So SRE and DevOps try
to solve this problem.
So why is this problem so bad?
If you think about the way that
we used to operate services--
I was a sys admin way
back in the day, right?
We used to have a
world in which people
who are product developers
wanted to ship features
as quickly as possible.
And then you had
operators who were
told, keep the system
as stable as possible.
We want 100%.
And these two interests
are in diametric opposition
to each other, right?
You have product developers
who are speaking the software
engineering language,
who are saying,
why is my feature not out yet?
And you have operators that are
saying my boss will punish me
if I don't get 100% up time.
You can't ship that feature.
So that's not a
very healthy state.
So how do we get
out of this state?
The good news is we
have some lessons
that we've learned from
the practice of agile,
from the practice of making
sure that your product
management and your
software engineering teams
are on the same page
as each other, right?
That's what agile is about.
Agile is about kind of
reducing that barrier,
reducing friction, shipping
smaller increments faster.
And the good news
is that DevOps is
a way of solving this
problem and solving
this wall between
development and your software
operations team, right?
And it says that you need
to break down that wall.
So DevOps is kind of
an abstract interface.
It says that it's a set of
practices and guidelines
that say you should make
sure that you dismantle
these walls between IT,
operations, software
development, and so forth.
But it doesn't say exactly how
do you go about doing that,
right?
It leaves a lot of it up to you,
as the person implementing it,
to figure out what
you want to do.
In comparison, SRE, or site
reliability engineering,
it's a set of practices that
were originally developed
at Google and have spread
across the industry.
And it's much more prescriptive.
It says here are some
practices, here are
some concrete beliefs
and philosophies,
and here is a job role.
You'll notice that
as much as people
like to hire for
DevOps engineers,
there is no such thing
as a DevOps engineer.
Whereas you can hire a
site reliability engineer
and have a relatively
clear idea of what
does that job description mean.
So what is in that job
description, right?
The core idea behind
SRE's solution
to this problem of the wall
with development and operations
is that we have to use data
to guide our decision making.
SRE says that we need
to treat operations just
like any other part of
software engineering, that we
need to really
engineer things, right?
That we need to write automation
to deal with our problems,
that we need to not be doing
things by hand all the time.
And that furthermore,
we can't bolt reliably
on after the fact, that
we have to make sure
that our systems are
engineered to be reliable
right from the start.
In terms of what SRE
teams actually do,
we are a solution for
having your systems
run at large scale scalably,
reliably, and efficiently.
So I don't have
time to go into kind
of all of these
detailed practices, kind
of core competencies that
SREs are expected to have.
For more information
on that, you
can go to a talk
tomorrow afternoon.
But I did want to
quickly summarize kind
of what are the areas, right?
SREs think about
metrics and monitoring.
How do we know whether
our systems are working?
How do we debug them?
How do we make sure
that our systems
can scale up appropriately?
How do we make sure that
we can push software
to production in a safe manner?
And when things do break,
how do we make sure
that we get the system
back within parameters
in a reasonable amount of time?
And overarching
all that, we like
to think about the culture.
How do I keep operating
the software at scale
without causing myself
to burn out not today,
not tomorrow, but a year
from now, two years from now,
three years from now?
So that's kind of in general
what we think about as SREs.
And you may be asking, OK,
so you said a bunch of stuff.
How does this relate to DevOps?
So I said earlier that DevOps
was an interface, right?
That it was an abstract
interface that said here's
some general ideas.
It's up to you to figure
out how to do them.
So these are the
five areas of DevOps.
DevOps says that
you need to reduce
your organizational silos.
It says that we need to have
an idea of failure as normal
rather than expecting 100%.
It says that we need to
gradually roll things out,
that we need to gradually
change or our processes,
and that we need to use
tooling and automation,
and that we need
to use measurement
as the centerpiece
of everything.
So it turns out the
SRE and DevOps are not
that far apart from each other
and that every single practice
that DevOps says you should
have an implementation
for, SRE does this.
So today, we're going to tell
you about two specific ways
that SRE implements DevOps.
Specifically, we're
going to be telling you
about error budgets,
and we're going
to tell you about how to
reduce the cost of failure.
So hopefully we can go
into a fair bit of depth
here so that you have
an idea of concretely
how can Stackdriver,
how can GCP help you
in each of these two areas.
So Marie, why don't you
tell us about error budgets?
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
All right.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
about error budget and SLOs.
Now, one of the
core observations
of site reliability
engineering came
from Ben Treynor Sloss, who's
the head of all SREs at Google.
And he noticed that 100% is the
wrong target for everything.
Like pacemakers, maybe.
Nuclear missiles, maybe.
But pretty much
everything else, you
don't need 100% reliability.
And why is this?
If you're running an app, the
network is not 100% reliable.
Your user's phones
are not 100% reliable.
They can't tell if it's
your app, or the network,
or your phones.
Also, additional
levels of reliability
require additional expense.
Google has observed
that for every nine,
you add reliability.
And we'll talk about what
that means in a minute.
You're adding 10x the expense.
So it gets much,
much more expensive.
You hire ops people.
You have to have additional
fallbacks and fail-safes.
And you have to build for it.
Since we're not the
airline industry mostly,
we don't need to.
So how do we figure this out?
We use a concept
called error budgets.
And in order to define
an error budget,
product management
and SREs will talk
and will figure out what
we think the users are
going to be happy with.
And from that, we subtract
whatever level of availability
we think the users
need from 100%.
And the amount that's
left is the amount
we're allowed to be
down in a given window.
So that's our error budget.
Once we have an error
budget, we need to track it.
It's really important
that we monitor
the actual availability,
because otherwise,
we don't know how much of our
budget we've gone through.
It's like if you have
a budget for spending
and you don't track
how much you spend,
then it's not all that useful.
And when you're
monitoring that, it
gives you a control loop
for your error budget.
If you have a ton to spend,
then you can do more releases.
You can have more features.
If you run out or
you're running low,
you need to be
more conservative,
because you know that your
users are going to be unhappy.
So how do we
measure reliability?
What is this metric?
There's a naive approach,
which is to say, OK, well,
we can figure out availability.
That's the number of good
minutes over the number
of total minutes.
And that's the amount of
time a service is working.
There are some advantages
to this approach.
It's super intuitive,
and it's pretty easy
to measure for a continuous
binary metric like uptime.
There is one major
disadvantage, which
is how many of us
are running services
that are actually up or down?
It's really hard for distributed
systems to make sense of this.
So there's a more
sophisticated approach
that you may want
to use as well,
which looks at interactions.
You take the good interactions
over the total interactions,
and that's the
fraction of real users
for whom the system is working.
Another advantage of this
is it brings the focus back
to the user, who's really
the person we're concerned
about in the first place.
So this handles our
distributor requests
response services well.
And it enables cases
like is something that's
down and not getting requests?
Do we care?
No, because we're not
getting any interactions.
If a few of our
services are down
and they are getting requests,
what's our availability?
We look at the interactions.
There we go.
This is a hard-to-read chart.
For me at least, when I think
about 99% or 99.9% or 99.99%,
it's a little difficult
to keep those straight,
because they're
all really similar.
They're all really high numbers.
It's more useful for me to
think about the error budget
that I'm allowed.
Per 30 days, for
instance, if I have
three nines of availability,
that's 43 minutes of downtime.
If I have four nines,
that's 4.32 minutes.
So there is a
dramatic difference
if I'm operating a system in
how I need to react to an outage
if I'm expected to have
four nines of availability.
LIZ FONG-JONES: The other really
interesting thing about this,
of course, is that we're
assuming 100% down here.
But earlier, Maria, you were
talking about bad interactions
and good interactions.
So if I were serving
10% errors, I
might still be able to
have 99.99% of my requests
complete successfully over
30 days for up to 40 minutes
if I were only 10% down
rather than 100% down.
So it lets us be a lot more
nuanced about approaching this.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Yup, but that's
real hard to represent in a
table, so this is what you get.
A glossary of terms before
we go into more of this.
I'm going to be talking
about several of these.
A service level
indicator, or SLI,
is a well-defined
metric of good enough.
And that's what we were talking
about before, your metric that
helps you figure out
your error budget.
A service level objective
is a top line target.
So you combine this
with an SLI and that
tells you what your goal is.
And a service level agreement
is a legal agreement
between you and a user.
If you fall below your SLA, then
there's some sort of penalty.
Usually, you will pay the user.
We won't really be talking
about SLAs in this talk,
because neither
of us is a lawyer.
And we think the operations
side is more interesting.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
to talk concretely
briefly about what an SLI
is and what an SLO is,
you can think about
an SLO as being,
like, I want this
request to the home page
to complete in 300 milliseconds.
If it completes in 300
milliseconds, the SLI is good.
And if it completes in
more than 300 milliseconds,
then the SLI has gone sour.
The users are not quite happy.
And the SLO is the
top line target
that says that we expect
99.99, for instance, percent
of those requests to complete
successfully over a window,
to make it a little
bit more concrete.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
That's exactly right.
So how does Stackdriver help
you with SLO monitoring?
We have an EAP product that
allows you to define, track,
and alert on SLOs directly
within Stackdriver monitoring.
I'm just going to walk
you through the UI.
It's very intuitive.
The first step is to
figure out if you're
going to have a latency
or availability SLI.
If it's latency, you'll define
a number of milliseconds.
The second is to
look at the period.
In this case, we're looking
at a week or a month.
And the third is to look
at your goal or your SLO.
Now, based, again,
on our research,
three nines you can get from
well-engineered software.
Four nines, you can get from
well-engineered operations.
And five nines, you need a
well-engineered business that's
really focused on availability.
And as you'll see from these
very cunning dollar signs
that we've put on here,
it gets incrementally more
expensive for
every nine you add.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
you may want to think
about does it really matter
if your users see downtime
for four seconds per month?
Maybe, maybe not.
It's an important
thing to think about.
What is your specific use case?
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And then we
have a review, where we
confirm that it looks right.
We submit, and we
start tracking.
So once we're tracking our SLO
within Stackdriver monitoring,
this is what it looks like.
We get three graphs.
Availability-- in this
case, in the calendar week.
And it shows us what
our SLO target is.
We have our error budget,
and how we're doing.
And we have our SLO compliance.
So in this case, we're
not doing so great.
LIZ FONG-JONES: No,
not doing well at all.
So now that we've defined or
service level objectives, you
may ask, that's great, but how
do you actually defend them?
How do you actually make sure
that you meet your service
level objectives?
So let's talk about
the life cycle.
Let's talk about how do we
manage to run a control loop?
How do we manage to
keep our services
running according to the
service level indicators
and the expectations?
So typically, your service
level objectives are met.
Maybe you have 0.5%
errors or 0.001% errors.
But in general, when your users
are happy, everything is fine.
But inevitably, faults
do happen in our systems.
Whether it's a code push,
whether it's a config push,
or a surge of the user
traffic, something
will happen inside of your
system that is a fault.
At that point, what happens
is your service level
indicators start going
sour, because users
are having a bad experience.
And Stackdriver SLO
might eventually
let you know that your
error budget is in danger.
So your alerting
might fire, and then
we have to do things as the
people who are responding,
right?
We have to see is everything
100% down globally?
If so, I might want to
involve more people.
Can I do something quickly
like draining a zone?
If so, maybe I'll do that.
But then after that,
we wind up spending
a lot of time, in the course
of figuring out what happened,
in this loop.
We wind up having to
formulate a hypothesis of what
we think broken our system.
And then we wind up having
to test the hypothesis
and actually verify is this
actually what is going on
in my system or did I come to
the wrong conclusion about what
is actually broken?
And assuming that you've
identified the right thing,
then you go and develop a fix.
Maybe it's provisioning
more capacity.
Maybe it is reverting
the bad rollout.
But you have to develop a fix,
and you have to test the fix.
And ideally, everything
goes back to normal, right?
Everything goes back
to nominal conditions,
and your SLO is met again.
Unfortunately, how
many of you have ever
had a situation where your
first guess was right about what
broke in the system, right?
How many of you-- it
happens every single time?
No one's raising their hands.
Good, none of you are
overconfident, right?
We spend a lot of time, because
our hypotheses are not always
correct, or our solutions are
not always correct, right?
So we wind up going back
to square one over and over
and over again.
So it's really, really
important for us
to both have high quality
alerting to make sure
that we find out quickly but
without waking us up too much,
and then we need to make
sure that we're actually
getting to testing and
formulating hypotheses
relatively quickly.
So let's start with the high
accuracy alerting bit, right?
We want to make sure that we
don't burn out, that we're not
getting paged 30 times in the
middle of the night at 2:00 AM
every single day.
At the end of the
day, what matters
is that we have to monitor
the symptoms of what
our users are actually seeing
and not every potential root
cause.
What do I mean by this?
Well, so users care if
they can use our service.
And getting alerted about
things that don't actually
impact your users doesn't
really matter, right?
Does it really impact your
users if one of your VMs
has its hard disk fill up?
Does it really matter?
Probably not, but it
kind of depends on what
your users are experiencing.
So what about if your
paxos quorum changes?
Or what about if the seat
you load on one machine
is too high?
Or what if the queue length
on your [INAUDIBLE] queue
is too long?
Or what if your task restarts?
Or what if the
kernel panics, right?
Like, all of these possible
things that could possibly
go wrong, not every single one
of them is worth waking up for.
So it turns out that
there's a better way
of thinking about this, right?
Because if we're already
measuring your service level
objectives, your
service level objectives
are measuring user happiness.
So what you care
about is figuring out
is your user happiness impacted?
For instance, if I had
an availability SLI that
said this is the
fraction of HTTP 500s
that I'm willing to
serve, and any more
than that is not acceptable,
that is an end user symptom.
How many 500s am I serving?
And I can use that
to my advantage
to replace all of those other
alerts that I showed you
and get rid of them, because
all I care about is, are
my users seeing errors or not?
But there also has to be
another strategy to this,
because we need to make
sure that we don't have
too many false alarms, right?
But that we also detect
low level degradations
in our systems.
So we have to go back to
our service level objective
and say, what's an
acceptable burn rate?
And how will I know quickly
enough to react in the event
that I'm going to consume
weeks of my error budget
in a matter of hours
or minutes, right?
As well as being able to
keep track of am I having 10%
more errors than I am allowed?
Am I getting instead of
0.1% errors, 0.11% errors
over a longer window?
So this means that
I need to think
about what are my thresholds.
I need to think about the math.
I need to say, if
I'm overspending,
and I'm spending five hours of
error budget in a single hour,
I should probably
fire off a page.
I should probably wake
someone up and have
them immediately deal with it.
Or if I've overspent by
5% or 10% over a few days,
it's been going
on for a few days.
It will probably
take multiple weeks
to burn through my error budget.
It can wait until the
next business day,
it can wait for
someone to look at.
It's still urgent, but not
waking-someone-up urgent.
And that way, you
get enough time
to get that statistical
signal of is
something actually broken.
So essentially,
what we've done is
we said, if we overspend by
too much within a given window,
for instance, one hour, that
we need to fire that page.
But also, if we burn faster
than five or 10 times
the rate that I'm allowed
in my budget-- for instance,
if I wind up burning
through seven
hours of error budget
in five minutes,
I'll get notified right away.
There's no need to
wait the full hour.
Similarly, we can talk about
the slow burn case, right?
We can say, OK, I'm going
to measure over three days,
and if I see 5% more
errors than I expect,
then I'm going to file a ticket.
I'm going to get a Jira
ticket or whatever, right?
Or if I even cross that
threshold within one day,
I can still get a
ticket and deal with it,
and it'll be fine.
So the good news
is you don't have
to implement all of
that math yourself,
because Stackdriver SLO will
deal with that problem for you.
Stackdriver SLO will let you
send alerts when your error
budget starts being exhausted.
It will project out
into the future,
and it will say, if I'm
going to exhaust my error
budget within a
certain window of time,
then I need to be alerted.
Or if I have less than
10% of my error budget
for the month remaining
or for the week remaining,
to alert me.
And that is how you get rid
of all of those potential
cause-based alerts and
instead replace them with
service-level-objective-based
monitoring.
So that's great, right?
We've now addressed the
time-to-detect problem.
But let's talk also about
the time-to-resolve problem,
because that's also an
equally important part
of having a resilient service.
So
When users see errors, now
we have our service level
indicators going sour.
Stackdriver SLO alerts
us, because we're
burning through our
error budget too fast.
What do we need to do?
As I said earlier in
the debugging cycle,
we need to prioritize speed
of our mitigation recovery.
So this is where a technique
called layer peeling comes
into good effect.
And it helps us localize
problems within our stack.
What zone is it coming from?
Which Kubernetes pot is
it coming from, right?
These are useful questions that
we need to be able to answer.
So I'm showing you
how Google SREs debug
tooling using our internal
infrastructure, which has then
influenced Stackdriver
to develop features
that help everyone do
it rather than requiring
you to be a Google SRE.
So in this example--
for instance,
let's say that I've
been paged for a latency
service level indicator, right?
That I've started seeing that
my 95th percentile latency
has gone over 100 milliseconds.
So I might need to do something
like ask a question, like,
hey can you break this down for
me by zone within the region?
So if I do that, then I might
get useful data that says,
hey, US West 1b has
been slow for a while,
but that's not where
the excursion came from.
The excursion came
from US West 1a.
And then I can drill
down into US West 1a,
and I can see that it's
two specific replicas that
are slow.
And then I can even do something
more sophisticated and say,
you know what?
Show me a heat map, right?
To show me the details of what's
the distribution of requests
that are slow.
And then we'll give me a
signal of, for instance,
all of the queries on this task
are slow because of the fact
that there is a noisy neighbor.
And then I might drain it
away from that machine, right?
So it provides you with an
actionable way of drilling down
into your data.
And the good news is that this
is fully implemented inside
of Stackdriver instead
of the Metrics Explorer.
So you can go into
the Metrics Explorer,
and you can ask questions,
and you can tell it to filter,
and then you can tell it to
group by a specific thing.
So in the earlier
example, I said
I wanted to filter by
region and group by zone.
And then I wanted to
filter by zone and group
by pod, for instance.
And then filter by
pod, and then group
by individual task number.
So that's how we
think about being
able to apply this SRE
technique from Google
inside of Stackdriver.
So Stackdriver
Metrics Explorer is
really handy for doing
these drill downs,
because if you can't localize
problems within your stack,
you're taking random
guesses, right?
You're kind of playing
whack-a-mole, seeing
whether your latest
hypothesis actually
is where the problem is.
It's better to not guess.
It's better to know by
exploring your data by the hag's
of where it came from
the second technique I'm going
to tell you about with regard
to helping you with
debugging problems faster
and reducing your
time to recover
is joining to be able to
cross-correlate problems inside
of your stack.
What do I mean by cross
correlating problems
in your stack?
Well, often, it turns
out to be the case
that we have pushed
something not
to any one individual Kubernetes
pod or any individual zone
or region, but
instead that something
has happened under the hood.
For instance, maybe someone
went and silently updated
the Java virtual machine
across our entire fleet, right?
So if you look at
all of the data,
you might just see noise
because of the fact
that there's no one
particular place that's
coming from some tasks
are slower than others.
So how do we get useful
signal out of this?
What we have to be
able to do is we
have to be able to combine
latency data with other data,
such as what version
of the kernel
we're running, for instance.
So we do this all
the time at Google,
where we add additional
information that
is collected elsewhere
in the system
and combine it
with existing data.
And once we have
that additional data,
we can go ahead and say, hey,
I want the average latency
by kernel version.
And if I do that, I get
signal out of my noise.
And that signal tells me, hey,
that kernel version suddenly
started having a
regression, where
previously all I saw was noise.
So how can you do this inside
of Stackdriver, you may ask?
The answer is that
inside of the Metrics
Explorer, any other
view within Stackdriver,
you can select not only
location-based information,
but you can also select
for system properties that
are embedded inside of the
data that you're exporting.
For instance, you can export
the container image ID out
of your Kubernetes
cluster in order
to get a delta between
two different values.
For instance, in
this example, we
have set up a Kubernetes pod
to serve 500s at a very--
to serve 500s very quickly,
because it's not taking
any time to do any real work.
And then meanwhile,
the control group
is serving a regular workload
and taking a normal amount
of time to do it.
So being able to do this
breakdown by version,
not necessarily localized to
any one particular location,
is really, really helpful.
The other thing
that's really cool
is that we have
upcoming a feature that
will allow you to issue
custom queries that are not
done through the
UI and are instead
done by typing in expressions.
So this lets you combine data
that you wouldn't ordinarily
be able to combine.
For instance, being
able to calculate
how many CPU seconds
does each query
take that my system
is receiving, right?
do you have to take the
total number of CPU seconds
on each task and divide it by
the total number of queries
on each task, which are metrics
that you wouldn't ordinarily
be able to combine.
So this core idea that I'm
trying to get across to you
is that having your
metadata available to you
inside of Stackdriver
monitoring and having
the query notation
language available to you
is a critical tool for being
able to formulate and test
your hypotheses.
And it lets you find problems
that are not necessarily tied
to a specific location.
So you can today do
resource-metadata-based queries
easily within the generally
available product.
And we have Stackdriver
query notation
that's in preview that will
allow you to arbitrarily join
these metrics together.
And if you're interested in
learning more or putting this
to work, feel free to talk
to me afterwards or come
to the Fifth Nine Lounge on the
second floor of Moscone West.
The final technique
that I wanted
to show you for reducing
your time to resolve
is really, really powerful.
It has seriously changed
my life as an SRE.
And the technique
is called exemplars.
It lets you pinpoint problems
within your stack by letting
you reason starting
from specific examples.
What do I mean by this?
An exemplar is
essentially an association
of something high cardinality
with your existing
distribution-based data.
So it makes your
distributed traces really,
really useful and
actionable for you.
It makes your high
cardinality data tags really,
really useful and
actionable to you.
The way that it works is that
we keep inside of distributions
the notion of a time
slice in our bucket--
for instance, the window
between 2:50 PM and 2:55 PM--
and a value slice, which
is, for instance, the values
between 50 and 60 milliseconds.
So for each of those
buckets, we record
up to one example of a query
exhibiting those behaviors.
For instance, a
Stackdriver trace
that exhibits that latency
during that time window.
And then we can show you in
Stackdriver monitoring which
buckets have samples
and let you go look
at the samples in detail.
So as I said, this
is a technique
inspired by Google SREs.
We've been using this
for several years now.
And what do we actually
use it for at Google?
The answer is that we use it for
looking at long-tail problems.
For instance, it would be
prohibitively expensive for us
to record the
amount of time that
every single physical machine
in Google's fleet took to boot.
However, what I can do is I
can record only one example
for each of these
common case time values.
But I can also
record one example
for each of these
outlying values,
and I can find out,
as a person who
maintains the fleet of machines,
which specific machine should I
be looking for that
had a slow reboot time.
Or for instance,
another thing that I
can look at is if I have a
service level indicator that
is based off of a blackbox
prober-- for instance,
if I had a storage system,
where I was measuring
how quickly does it take to
write a query into the system,
what I might observe is if I had
a less sophisticated monitoring
system, all I would see is that
the 99th percentile is slowly
creeping up over time.
However, the cool thing is
that this heat map gives me
a visual representation
of the fact
that more and more
of these queries
are taking close to
N100 milliseconds.
But there's not really that
many queries over that value.
So I might ask
questions, like show me
an example of a query that
takes N100 milliseconds, right?
Show me an example of a
query somewhere in here
that is starting to
become very slow.
And I can then click on
it and find a Stackdriver
trace corresponding
to that slow event
so that I can start looking
at this long-tail problem
rather than having to
look through 20 or 30
different dashboards and guess
what I think is happening.
So this feature is going to be
available soon in Stackdriver
that lets you overlay individual
Stackdriver traces onto a heat
map of your latencies
and display it
alongside your service
level objectives.
So you can go directly
from having a service level
objective threatened to seen
concrete examples of queries
that caused your service level
indicators to become unhappy,
so that you can start debugging
and formulating hypotheses
faster.
With these culprit
traces in hand,
it helps you formulate
a hypothesis.
It helps you figure out,
which task do I need to go to?
Which Kubernetes pod
do I need to look at?
In order to figure
out which logs do I
need to look at, right?
Because it has a concrete time
stamp and machine name to go
look at.
You still need to be able
to dynamically evaluate
queries, which is where the
earlier section on joining data
comes from.
But even formulating
the hypothesis
is the thing that we find
we need to optimize for.
So exemplars and
Stackdriver are a way
of combining Stackdriver trace
and Stackdriver monitoring
all in one view and getting the
insights that you need faster.
So now you've
identified your problem
and you think it
might be Google.
What should I do, Marie?
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
So Liz talked you
through some techniques that
Google SREs use in order
to debug more effectively.
And I'm going to
show you something
that Google is providing
to you right now,
today, that will help
you easily identify
whether a problem that you've
seen is because of Google.
Now often, the first thing that
we'll do when we're debugging
is to try to figure
out roughly where
the problem's coming from.
Is it my code?
Is it the network?
Is it the infrastructure?
That can be a really
tricky thing to figure out,
so Google's
transparent SLIs help
you answer the question
of is this problem coming
from the infrastructure.
They give you the ability
to quickly understand
if an issue you're
seeing is correlated
with an issue in GCP.
And they give you
per project metrics
about your requests to help
you answer this question.
How might you use them?
For triage.
If you've gotten alerted
by one of your SLIs,
it's trending towards
violating your error budget.
This gives you a single place to
go to look at the GCP services
that your product depends
on, so you can tell.
And then for support.
If you do identify an issue,
when you call Google Support,
you'll be looking
at the same graph.
And that helps
make sure that you
start the conversation
on the right foot,
that you start the conversation
with a mutual understanding
of the problem, so you can move
quickly towards resolution.
So to view these--
again, these are your requests,
so they're per project.
And they're broken up
by a number of fields.
In the Metrics Explorer today--
you could go look
at this right now,
but please keep paying
attention to our talk.
Wait until after.
You'll search for consumed API.
And when you do this, you'll
see there four options--
request count, request
latency, request size,
and response size.
There are a number of
different labels supported.
This is a subset that
I've listed here.
The whole list would have
been totally illegible instead
of slightly illegible.
But this allows you
to break it down
by method, by project, or by
service, or by response code.
Maybe you're suddenly seeing an
uptick in a specific response
code, and you want it to dig in.
And then, as with all
metrics in Stackdriver,
you can use group by or
filter to help refine, as Liz
was talking about earlier.
So how do you use these?
What we expect you
to do with these
is to look for correlated
SLI degradations.
Your product's SLI is
trending in a bad direction?
See if the GCP products
that it relies on
are also having anomalies.
Look at a baseline.
See what it looked like last
week or the previous day,
so that you know that it's
not some sort of cyclic thing
that wouldn't necessarily lead
to an issue in your product.
And use these to drive
support conversations.
This is going to
help you have really
efficient, effective
conversations with Google
Support.
Things not to do.
Please don't assume this
is an SLA for Google.
We are giving you this for
information to help you debug.
It's not an SLA.
And please don't call every
time there's an outlier.
I'm sure you have
better things to do,
and I'm sure support
folks do as well.
And lastly, set up alerts
based on your SLIs.
Don't set them up based on ours.
We care our users
are having trouble,
but you ought to care if your
users are having trouble,
not if Google is
being a little wacky.
If you'd like to
learn more about this,
there's a demo area on the
first floor of Moscone West.
If you go all the way
to the back of the room,
we're near the folks
in the red shirts.
Stackdriver PMs are
hanging out there
for the whole conference,
so come talk to us.
There's also a blog post coming
this week to the Google Cloud
blog, where you can
learn a lot more.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
to conclude, today we
talked about four
different things.
We talked about why should
you adopt SRE techniques,
how does SRE help solve
operational problems
that you may be having.
And then we talked about
three specific ways
of applying these
SRE techniques,
about how to measure your
success of your customers
using SLOs, how do we
reduce her time to resolve
and your time to detect
using SRE techniques,
and how do we
debug problems that
are somewhere between
Google and your own code
by using transparent SLIs.
So the key message that I want
you to walk away with today
is that SRE techniques help you
solve your cloud reliability
problems.
It may be really easy to click
a button in the GCP console
and get 10 times
as many servers.
You can't get 10 times
as many operations staff
at the click of a button.
So it means that we
really need to invest
in automation and
engineering for operability
in order to be successful
in our cloud deployments.
And furthermore, I want you
to walk away with the idea
that having product
development and operations
at each other's throats
is an unhealthy dynamic.
It doesn't need to exist.
That if you are
running your service
to a same set of metrics, if
you have error budgets and SLOs,
that it provides you with
common language and flexibility
to decide how fast can I push
without impacting my users
experience.
How can I make sure they get
both adequate reliability
and also shipping
our users' features
as quickly as possible?
The other thing I
wanted to mention
is that GCP helps you, right?
We're here to help you
achieve higher reliability.
achieve higher operability.
And the way that we do
that is that we embed
SRE concepts into Stackdriver
to help you operate more
like an SRE and that
our products build
in all of these
SRE best practices,
so that you can have
lower cost of ownership,
so that you can reduce the
tension between your teams,
and so you can scale up.
So I promised I'd tell
you a little bit more
about my team, the Customer
Reliability Engineering Team.
So we're a set of experienced
Google Site Reliability
engineers, and we've
shifted our focus.
Instead of focusing on
individual GCP products,
we focus on helping our
customers be successful,
helping our customers
be reliable.
And what form does that take?
Well, we help our customers set
service level objectives that
are meaningful to their users.
We help people do
reliability reviews.
You can tell, is my
application engineered
to meet these service level
objectives that I think
will make my customers happy?
And if not, we'll
give you a list
of items that will
help you decide
where do I want to invest my
time to make my system more
operable.
We also do shared
monitoring, right?
So Marie told you about having
visibility of Google service
level indicators to
you, the customer.
However, we also think that
it's important to have support
on the same page,
that it should be
possible for you, as
a customer of GCP,
to expose your service
level indicators
and objectives to us,
so that support can see,
on one page, your service
level indicator being impacted
and a GCP service level
indicator being impacted and be
able to debug and know
is the problem fixed
or not without having to
call you up and ask you,
is it better yet?
So we do things
like shared learning
as well, so that we'll
get proactively notified
if a number of customers
start experiencing
an issue with
their service level
objectives in a
correlated fashion.
We also help people that
are large customers--
for instance, retailers--
with critical periods
like Black Friday.
And then we help you
with ongoing operations,
things like doing a joint
post-mortem whenever
there is a outage.
Maybe there's something that
you could do to mitigate
and that we could
do to mitigate.
There's not a reason
to do only one of them.
We should do both.
And we help people be more
reliable all the time,
whether it be looking
at your design documents
or helping you do
disaster drills.
So you can learn more about
SRE, both from reading the Site
Reliability Engineering
book, the first one,
which is available for free
online at google.com/sre.
You can also go and pay us
a visit at the Fifth Nine
Lounge, which is located on the
second floor of Moscone West.
And there, we're distributing
a book, print copies of a book
called The Site Reliability
Workbook, which just came out
today fresh off the presses.
We'll even sign a copy for you.
And furthermore,
there's a book coming up
in the next month
called Seeking SRE,
which was written by a person
who doesn't work at Google.
And it's a compendium of
industry best practices,
both from Google and
from outside of Google.
The Site Reliability Workbook
also includes lessons
from our customers.
Another place you may
want to go to learn more
is to attend Jess and Anne's
talk at 4:45 PM tomorrow.
I believe it is in Moscone West.
So with that, we have 10
minutes for questions.
So please raise your
hand, and someone
will bring a microphone around.
And we'll try to answer
any questions that we can
with the remaining time.
Thank you very much
for listening to us.
[APPLAUSE]
Question down there
in the middle, please.
Please pass the microphone down.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
LIZ FONG-JONES: It's on.
Just start talking.
AUDIENCE: Those-- all
those metrics there,
seem like you're pulling
them from APIs and stuff.
Can you pull all
that information also
from Google load balancer?
LIZ FONG-JONES: From the
Google load balancer, you said?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
The Google load balancer
metrics are given to you
through Stackdriver, right?
AUDIENCE: I haven't seen--
we've been using Google
load balancer for a while,
and I have not seen any where to
pull response codes, the times,
and anything.
So right now, we
have built nginx
in the middle between
Google load balancer
and whatever the backend is
just to pull out metrics.
So after seeing all
your presentation,
I was really curious on
how we can get metrics out
of the Google load balancer.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Can you come chat with us
at the Transparent SLIs?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
We'll figure it out.
AUDIENCE: Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Over there.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Any other questions?
OK.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Can someone
run that microphone over there,
please?
And then after that, we'll
run the microphone over there
to the end, and then
we'll go back over.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
LIZ FONG-JONES: All
right, go ahead.
The floor is yours.
AUDIENCE: Do you support
custom sources for the SLIs?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
That is something
that we are working on.
We decided that it
was most important
to prioritize people's kind of
HTTP statuses and latency first
before we worked on
supporting custom metrics.
So that is something we're
very much interested in.
We're interested
in your feedback.
Like we said, this
is a early access.
Over there.
Someone can run that over there.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And as that's happening,
I think we forgot
to mention-- please
rate our talk in the
app, so that we know
how we can do better next time.
AUDIENCE: This might
be an unfair question,
but you're introducing
a culture shift
and thinking that sometimes
my executives might have issue
with.
Do you have tips or
case studies on how
introducing SLI versus uptime
improves their business?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
You want to attend
Jess and Anne's talk
at 4:45 PM tomorrow, which is
all about the culture shift.
There's also a concrete customer
case study at the Fifth Nine
Lounge, I believe, on
Thursday afternoon,
where we'll have a
customer that I've
been working with for several
months called Marketo, which
we'll be talking
about their experience
with adopting their SRE culture.
Over here in the front.
AUDIENCE: So my customers--
it's not about uptime.
It's about serving X amount
of requests by Y date.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yup.
AUDIENCE: So how
would I design metrics
around, hey, we're getting
close, and this is dangerous?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That is a
difference between a service
level objective and a
service level agreement
is that you want
your service level
objective to be set more
aggressively than your service
level agreement.
So you will get
paged before you run
into the danger
zone and fall afoul
of your legal obligations.
So you might want to
set, for instance,
a service a little objective on
throughput with the idea being
that if your service level
objective starts degrading,
like, if you have
your throughput
degraded below the level
that you would need in order
to complete everything in
the requisite amount of time,
that you would start
getting alerted about it.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yes, a lot.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Great.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's loud.
Sorry.
So you mentioned alerting
on SLO violations
instead of alerting
on root causes.
In my experience, root causes.
sometimes are leading
indicators of SLO violations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do
you feel about that?
And how do you approach that?
LIZ FONG-JONES: If a root
cause is very, very, very
strongly correlated in
an advanced predictor,
then it winds up sometimes
being a good idea
to alert in advance.
However, most of the
time that is not true.
Most of people's
potential causes
are in fact only potential.
So I would say it's probably
OK to have maybe three or four
potential causes.
It's probably not OK
to have 100, right?
You kind of have to have
balance in all things.
At the end of the day, it
also depends upon your window
to react, right?
If you have a three-nines SLA,
that gives you enough time
to investigate something.
And if you have a
five-nines SLA--
or sorry, if you have
a five-nines SLO,
maybe you're better off
implementing some kind
of automation to deal
with the condition
that reliably, predictably
leads to degradation
in service, right?
You would rather write a
robot to do that for you
rather than alert you with,
hey, this thing's in danger,
and it always
leads to a problem,
and you always do
the same thing.
Why not have a robot
do that for you?
Other questions.
Over here in the front.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
It's coming.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Yeah, it's coming.
It's coming.
AUDIENCE: So there are
a lot of Google services
that we use where there is
a time for data propagation.
So for example, when you add
a user to a group in G Suite--
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yup.
AUDIENCE: --or when
you change and I
am role or something like that,
it says it could take a minute
or it could take up to 24 hours.
How do you decide
your internal targets
versus what you say in
the documentation, what
that delta really is?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That's a
product management thing.
Marie.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
[LAUGHS] Thanks, Liz.
You're a real pal.
It's going to vary
depending on the service.
And what it will depend
on is exactly what
we talked about,
which is what we think
the users are looking for.
So for something like
adding an I am role,
you probably expect a
much quicker turnaround.
Whereas if you're
sending logs to a storage
bucket for cold storage,
then you can wait.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm more
thinking what the gap is,
though.
So a lot of times, we
see that a propagation
could take up to 24 hours.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES: Right.
AUDIENCE: But the reality
is it's, like, five minutes.
So there's a huge gap between--
LIZ FONG-JONES: Ah, yes.
That's a fascinating question.
AUDIENCE: --what's normal
and t hen what we--
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yeah,
we love that question.
So that is an example
where the service level
objective and the
real user experience
have diverged from each other.
And in those cases,
it is usually
a thing we recommend
as an SRE best
practice-- sorry to make more
work for you, Marie, right?
But we usually recommend
as a best practice
to either make sure that
the SLOs reflect reality
or to degrade reality in order
to match the SLOs, right?
In order to make
sure that people
get predictable,
consistent performance.
So yes, you're right to
note that that is a gap.
And that is something
where we probably
should either tighten
one or loosen one, right?
Like when you have
an aspirational SLO
and an actual,
on-the-ground SLO that
are de facto different from
each other, that's a problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
typically wouldn't
expect them to be orders
of magnitude apart.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly, not
orders of magnitude apart.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES: We'll
go ahead and make that slower
then.
[LAUGHTER]
LIZ FONG-JONES: Any
other questions?
One more question.
We've got two minutes left.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
choosing your SLIs to match
what your users care about.
Is there value in trying to
go beyond just an HTTP 500
in that sometimes
a 400 is actually
a problem in our client,
that the user is--
it's still a
problem to the user,
but those can be a lot harder
to detect and understand
in a useful way.
LIZ FONG-JONES: That gets
to Marie's discussion
of measuring user journeys
rather than single requests.
So if you can measure an entire
user journey-- for instance,
measuring not
just, you know, did
loading the home page of
my shopping website work,
but was I, in fact, able
to add an item to a cart
and check out?
That's going to be a much
more robust situation.
So the same thing goes
for HTTP 400s, right?
Like are users experiencing
what they are expecting to see?
Or are users expecting
an abnormal condition?
And that's something that
you need to make sure that--
the best possible SLO is
a critical user journey,
but you have to start
somewhere, right?
An imperfect SLO is
better than no SLO.
So start measuring,
otherwise you're
just taking stabs in the dark.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And so a better framing
of that might be
something that's not a 200
would be a failure rather
than a 500 is a failure.
All right.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Excellent.
Thank you all for coming.
And if you want to
find us afterwards,
you can find us
at the Fifth Nine
on the second floor
of Moscone West.
MARIA COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]